[Music]
hi
uh how is this going hope you guys are
having a great day
i just accidentally started
so argo my laughter
but everything is fine just ben simon's
probably having
a heart attack
don't worry about it this is the um this
is what i want to show i was trying to
stop the voice i'm hearing myself down
here and there we go
great so happy tuesday everybody
uh welcome to another tuesday of chess
and psychology
um today i kind of want to show you some
dynamic games
and that was a great start i'm never
going to cut my hair
kidding me no no no no this is my
secret to warmth but um
yeah so i want to show you some nice
games in dynamic chess
so i'm going to show you i'm going to
start with a game that braunstein played
in 1956
yes and follow up with hopefully
uh one or two of topalov games so that
those are some of my favorite um cool
dynamic game i got the idea of talking
about dynamics because when in camps i'm
talking about so
who can tell me like what's the
difference it's like a dynamic hearing
and like a strategy game
like they all have the idea that
dynamics should be like
faster more like just higher pace just
like
a lot of different um well dynamic is
much different from strategy
strategy game so um just like the
how to have the balance how to convert
it stuff like this
is something that a lot of players
struggle with so
um yeah okay so i want to try my best
and show you some dynamic games
so without much talk
let's just start so this game
is the game that branston played
uh i do not know the opponents but
black was um roja
rojo i i do not unfortunately i don't
know this player i
wish i did but before my time
so now we got what the americans know as
fried liver attack but i grew up knowing
this as just a
just don't do this attack but
as black just to be careful just like a
trick
i didn't really know the name for it but
you americans know
the names which is kind of cool fried
liver why not
so i have had the experience of this pla
this position from blackside
many years ago but my opponents usually
always just went for this bishop b5
nobody
really played this d3 so what are your
thoughts
uh on d3 what do you think should be do
you think
um this changes anything for the black
are we going to take on
c4 are we not going to take on c4
i'd highly doubt anybody will want to
take knight face d5 right now
either but so yeah just let me know what
you think about this
uh stefan i think you need
it would be better if you wore it a
little bit better i
don't understand that because but
um yeah i kind of i'm kind of used to
bishop b5 seeing bishop b52
so h6 is actually a little bit more
interesting just because now you kind of
kick this knight away
and now you can actually consider taking
back on
d5 however here black played e4
and it's my understanding that e4 is um
kind of interesting but not something
that i would do honestly as black
i'm more inclined to like taking first
and then doing e4
or taking on d5 but then taking on d5
has issues with taking on e5
i like take takes like something with
c4s just like stuff like that it's
not going to be as pleasant
so having said that e4
my question to you guys shall we take
this pawn
are we going to take d takes e4 or let's
ignore it what do you think we should do
something we could consider is queenie
too
so this has like a
kind of interesting background um
like so
from what i know from this game uh
braunstein wanted to do the sacrifice
so i'm sure you guys uh
know how big paul morphy is well was but
how much impact he has in our uh today's
chess
and like the history and everything that
he did for
today's chess um
and so what i kind of wanted to talk
about was in this game
branston kept thinking so what would
paul murphy do if he was white
after e4 would he sacrifice it because
especially last week
on the chest in psychology we went over
some of the morpheus games
the nightlist games that he was putting
like his b1 knight off the board go off
the board there we go
nope all right well this knight doesn't
want to god there we go not my knights
off the board
he would have this like games that he
was playing with from first move
thank you without knight and uh i
thought that was quite interesting
so now in this game branston is thinking
to himself
uh actually thought to himself um that
so what would morphy do would he take
here and sacrifice this
this bishop or would you just go on
queen e2 i agree it kind of depends on
what his opponent's rating
today i would definitely that would be
definitely one of my considerations
however
um that in this was a this was a game
that was happening in the olympia
olympias are teams right right so you
need to um
you need to you need to think of
the good of the team not just yourself i
agree morphe would most likely take
however braunston in this position asked
permission
from his team to sacrifice i don't know
i don't know the rule back then but this
is something that was kind of big that
like
he actually asked permission to do like
a sacrifice
i'm like yeah getting a
permission to sacrifice but i guess this
is just
um how this kind of shows like how
awesome
i want i don't wanna say awesome how uh
united the
soviet players back in the 50s were
so yeah it was really interesting
to me to like to what he had that he got
permission
but yeah so i guess they permitted him
to do this take of course
and now what how do you think we should
follow we probably should do something
fast because now this is a dynamic
position we gotta be able to
actually use this position otherwise we
are going to
suffer suffer seriously because well we
just gave up the
we just gave up the the bishop right
so we need two is possible queen of two
was possible i agree
but um i think this is
this is more interesting and kind of
that's why we're looking at probably if
queenie two we wouldn't be spending so
much time looking at it
right so
um c3 e5 so em e5 takes on d5
so in the game uh y20 queen d4
so the idea with queen d4 is kind of
interesting the idea
is well i'm centralizing my queen
i'm attacking your knight um i'm taking
away your
potential bishop c5s so
i think these are some of the
interesting things that was considered
during the game
and yeah so in the game uh black just
went knight b6
but the better was knight d6 actually
if you played e5 then there's knight f5
and then
um the pawn is also hanging so this e5
is the wrong move
however i think knight d6
knight c3 this is still pretty
interesting
position for white but knight d6
is just a little bit better compared to
knight
b6 because after knight b6 we are not
forced to play knight c3
and so we have smooth c4
all right so what i think will happen
after c4
uh does anybody actually want to be
white anybody want to be black
let's try to take like a quick
vote hello guys how's it going
i'm kind of happy to be back in the
chess club for the time being
i was going a little i was getting a
little repetitive from my
room then to library room library room
library
so i'm actually going to library after
here
but yeah i do prefer y2 just spatial
wise this is awesome
um and it's not just one pawn we have
two pawns
in exchange for knight so yeah i like c4
so
c6 seems to be the best move
because you got to try and attack the
center however
in the game black played c5 now what do
you think we should do should we should
we do this on poisson
should we ignore should basically we
have two choices
either ambassador or move the queen
somewhere else
which one do you think is better
yeah we shouldn't have some we shouldn't
trade queens exactly
good so we should just retrieve the
queen uh queen d3 seems to be the
the best position because you don't i
mean your queen is um
defending your pawns and it's just right
behind the structure and you can start
considering something with e5s as well
knight c3 e5 those looks pretty good
right
in the game black played bishop g4
now i want you guys to try and give me
like a brief
overview of what are you going to do
with your pieces so
what are you going to do with this
knight what are you going to do with
your king this bishop
just where do you think they belong and
ideally a move order like
um but not necessarily so i
basically just want you to tell me where
your pieces should be
um i think yeah knight probably should
be on somewhere
most likely d2 but then what if the
knight is on d2
then what are you gonna do with your
bishop that's the thing if you play
knight c3
can't he just take it if you take with
the queen then he can try to take over
here
and if you take with the pawn you kind
of mess up with your pawn structure
so i think um having understood that
you're gonna most likely choose knight
d2
even though d2 is not at the most ideal
position that's the position that
defends f3
so we're gonna go for knight d2 um
and so after knight d2
black actually played bishop e7 now
i think castling is not something that's
it's too hard for us to see
castling seems pretty doable castle
and um now
why to move what to do i would want to
free this bishop
but is it should we like try to freeze
from f4 should it drive with b3s
i think considering b3 is very
reasonable
however what about this knight what are
you going to do with this knight
so i see an idea with h3 so
if you're trying to kick that bishop
away you don't have to do it with
x3 you can't do it with knight e5
what do you guys think about that
okay um
yeah i think you guys are catching up
that's a nice e5 is like a better
version of playing h3
and yes i definitely agree
95 this little guy is going crazy over
here
and after a nice e5
[Music]
well we don't necessarily intend to take
on g4
but we intend so a lot of the lots of
the dynamic chess is about space
spatial advantage pieces of coordination
just trying to form an attack very
simply to put it
in game we're most often trying to like
regroup them
find the right pieces um plan long ahead
usually the pawn structures are quite um
quite determined in the um
in the strategy games but in dynamic
games it's not
that's not completely true we have like
a mobile center and mobile pawns
so yeah uh in the game
black just played bishop h5 now
though we have mentioned this idea with
b3 so let's go ahead and do it
um black played knight d7 so now my
question to you again what do you want
to do with this knight
you do have a few options you can do
something like f4
you can take and try with like e5 maybe
you can play bishop b2 um you can bring
the other knight to f3 so you do have a
variety of options which one do you
prefer
so you wanted to bring your knight from
d2 g3 f5
that's interesting but right now the
game is not in the king side or the
queen side it's more in the center
so whatever you do should have be doing
something to our center
and because we have sacrificed the
knight for two pawns
and this dynamic advantage that's the
thing with dynamic advantage you rarely
get the chance
to actually play a move like knight d2
rook d okay e1
knight f1 knight g3 that's going to be
way too slow
dynamic chess is quite fast paced
so 97
i'm not the honestly i'm not the biggest
son of f4 i think it's interesting but
it also has a lot of
uh little issues
huh on poisson yeah how can we
understand the knight
teach me d6 takes the
if you play d6 he's just gonna pick up
your knight and attack your queen so
careful guys
i don't think knight f3 is also a good
choice just because knight f3
um what if i just take it over here you
have to take back with the knight
and what if i just try to block it over
here
trying my best to block woof
so that's why here bishop b2 is just the
easiest way
um so ideally we want to take this
knight
but he's going to take it back with the
knight and then play bishop whoops doing
chess.com leeches
then do bishop f6 we're not gonna have
enough time
play this e5 that is why
we shouldn't take we should just go for
bishop b2
and after bishop b2 um
in the game take take knight d7 so now
we got to the say a similar position
that we were just looking at
attacking our bishop what to do
we could bring the bishop back we could
try something with maybe
f4 we could try something with i guess
those are your two valid choices
oh you got it ah that fly was really
beginning to frustrate me
i don't think the f4 is a good idea
sorry guys uh queen g3
oh careful
bye bye rook
exactly we need this bishop so we got to
keep it
so when we're keeping this bishop um
let's see what else can happen
um bishop c3 is just a little bit more
precise because if you play bishop b2
after bishop f6
you have to do something about this
bishop again and you would be losing a
tempo
um whoops you could play like rook b1
you could play like queen c2 you could
move this bishop whatever you do
you're gonna lose a tempo so that's why
we uh braunstein liked bishop c3
he doesn't want to lose the tempo
because then dynamic chess tempos matter
way too much to just throw them around
so
bishop c3 and
in the game black went for bishop f6
and now wise to move i'm gonna give you
guys about
30 seconds or maybe a minute max to just
try and tell me what you think
white should do
i would ideally like a like a like a
one or two moves like i do this opponent
does this then i'll do that
something like this
all right so i see some ideas i see f4 i
see lot of rook c1
i don't approve of taking on f6 because
queen takes and then your e5 square is
going to be blocked
we don't want opponents to block that
because those pawns are
are our golden boys we don't want to
lose them
or golden girls since start going to
become a queen
um so
um e5 it takes we have a fork be careful
e5
if it takes you go up there you could
just throw in like a check
eat over there eat over there
that's a possibility or just eat over
there
so we don't really want to give black
chance
so we mentioned this in dynamic chess
in this game specifically
this position you shouldn't give your
opponent's
chance to fix his position so
you should uh play it quite fast you
should
um you shouldn't give your opponent a
chance to to breathe you should
both yeah uh you shouldn't give your
opponent a chance to do something like
95 to take on c3
to like improve his position so not
necessarily eating
but he wants to improve the position
black needs some space
because his pieces are kind of tangled
so black needs to blockage
this e-pawn so we don't want to do that
we don't want to give opponent that's
so uh in this position um
white what do you guys think about this
rookie one
if you were to play something like
knight d5 okay now i go queen g3 now i
want to do f4 and then i'll do e5 and my
rook is ready to support this
pawn i did say suggestions of rookie one
earlier so
i kind of went ahead and just gave you
the answer however if take
take and queen f6 now what do you think
we should do
exactly e5 we shouldn't we shouldn't
exchange queens
point five then what how are we gonna
start pushing these guys
push it baby i see somebody has been
watching y'all sir
so i see a lot of e6 and d6 and just
push
but d6 right now doesn't help because
he's just gonna try to block it with
putting something on e6
e6 right now doesn't work because just
take take and just knight f6
it's it's premature uh b4
maybe but b4 not right now f4 f4 is the
way to go exactly
we want to do this f4 and we want to
bring this knight
we want to do this so we did this f4 to
protect our pawn so we can bring this
knight
right so
um f4 bishop g6
now can we still do this knight e4 is
there anything stopping
us
after queen f6 why queen is not queen
history all right we can um
so we can't simply do this um
knight e4 and that is something that
knight e4 happened
yep however um
let me go back a little bit to address
this question of
why not queen h3
it's a good question um
[Music]
the first thing that comes to mind is
knight e5
you take though and i can't really trap
your queen anyway
another thing that comes to mind is
something with
uh i want to say queen g5 because if you
take the knight i'll take your knight
yeah queen g5
and if you take that i'll take this
uh if you f4 queen g4
all right so let's go back to the game
e5 queen f5 f4 knight e4
so now what's the next move
all right so i see a lot of different um
ideas knight d6 keep in mind if you
touch that knight
he is gonna put that queen on d3 and one
exchange
he wants to exchange queens so
preferably don't do that
preferably simply just
try to improve your pieces instead of
giving your opponent chance to do
something like
um
going to d3 right
okay so
um one thing that we could do is
i see a lot of e6 and like trying to
just
[Music]
push
i'm trying to see i don't think anybody
has actually said the correct move
no what do you think about queen f3
so i see some yeses
i see some wows
um
so
what do you think like what is the idea
oh i see a long persian message
ah thank you that's that's quite
personal thank you for sharing
um
so yeah exactly we want to play g4 right
easy peasy
so in order to actually get that g4
um it is kind of
we want g4 opponent doesn't want to lose
the queen so probably has to do either
move the knight or move the bishop
in the game blacklight bishop h7 and g4
queen g6 f5 queen goes to b6
and this position you can already feel
the how
how strong this is like all of these
pawns are just
making this poor bishop and knight cry
like it's horrible
i wouldn't want to be black for a sake
of argument let's just take a
quick look at how this looks from black
oh
boy that stinks okay yeah that's
horrible i don't want to look at this
position from black
um yeah but it does have a huge amount
of space
so after queen b6 um
it's really important to figure out how
to continue
this is dynamic attack exactly so we
should we shouldn't rush it if we rush
with like e6
it's just it's not going to end very
well there's 95s as well
now now i was going to think
yeah 95s kind of starts to block it
over 95 right now so
my point is you shouldn't rush it so
exactly queen g3
thank you cut and
after um after queen g3
we have different ideas we might want to
do f6 we're going to do e6
i'm bigger fan of f6 to be honest so
black got a play f6 to stop us right
now why to move what to do are we going
to take that or are we going to play e6
i think either way this bishop is that's
just like looking
way too sad so
i see a lot of e6 yep you guys are
correct e6 is the best way
and after e6 uh black just played knight
e5
however this knight e5 is not the same
as 95 but the palm bay got e4
so now why to move how are we gonna win
you can
obviously see we have advantage but
converting the advantage to full point
is something that needs expertise
that's why we're here we're trying to
figure out how to do this conversion of
advantage to full point
um no d6 is still too early
so hold on let's take it let's take a oh
you're good
mati uh let's take a second and just
look over this position
so we are doing pretty cool in the
center
we're doing all right in the king side
but we could improve the king side right
there we go all right so
um after playing this h4 our idea is
clear we want to play this g5
probably g6 so eat the bishop so black
just went king h8
and he okay so black is really just
struggling
there isn't like a single thing that is
wrong with
d6 it's just not the most accurate way
the most accurate way is this h4 and g5
because even psychologically holding the
position
and bringing more pressure is way better
for
you than just um trying to push pawns
so this this the fact that he has to
deal with trying to keep the bishop
is another um psychological
warfare against uh black
alright so now um actually why did
something pretty chill
that kind of cracks me up king is one
it really does crack me up because it's
just such a simple move you want to play
simply rg1 probably take on i've seen
i just want to do simple stuff but my
point was that if even if you wanted to
do that why not why don't you just do
something like this
but anyways um king h1
queen d8 now um i guess if we played
rook g1
queen e7 but then there's d6 so i
don't fully follow why he didn't follow
up with the rook g1 idea
um here bonstein just went for
g6 take take and you see we already got
the bishop back
this is just looking way too good to be
true
exactly we're kind of showing who's the
boss psychologically too
so we started off this game at like move
what was
eight even i think was move eight uh we
just gave up a piece for two pawns and
now we got two pieces back in
within like two three moves so
and this is just how the game ends uh i
don't think knight f6 is the only way to
win
i don't think in a real life game i
would play knight f6
i would like to think i would but to me
something as simple as
can i just play like queen d6 i really
like something like queen d6
quite simple very charming i'm just
going to try and eat your pawns
or something like knight d6 if you take
knight f7 check
that's also pretty cool to me however
braunstein really wanted
boom boom boom boom and he took on df6
and um okay this is just
yeah this is just way too good the thing
is if take
take take this take and if you take with
the rook well the problem is
at the end rook f8 rook e8 right
and if you were to take that with
the pawn i believe just 3e7
is also super winning
i'm bringing g7 and you can't really
stop my attack when i do like even if
you do something like this
i'm still going to get 28 and i'm still
going to win a rook
all right so i saw there was a question
about move 24
knight d4 let's just jump to move 20
4. here
you think knight d4 was better than
queen f3 you checked it with the engine
and it says that queen train is actually
good for us because pawns are advanced
enough just i thought
um i don't disagree
but i also don't i wouldn't i would not
do that in the game so that's why i
don't really like to have like an engine
open when i'm analyzing the game with
you guys
because it's um
engine might be able to win that but for
human being
i want to keep my queen i want to attack
i want to be able to do that awesome g4
f5 g5 i want to push push push i don't
want to exchange queens and just rely on
these
i want more so that is why i don't think
humans would actually
want to exchange coins in this position
so yeah okay um
that is the game that i wanted to show
[Music]
you
all right uh let's move on to the next
game
um give me a second to f11 it
whoa is that the right f11
it's nope not that one not that one
wait where's my game
give me a second guys my game
oh i was going backwards ha that
explains it okay
um yeah i have it
so i think this game between topolof and
chapper enough
je perino
was great um
so all right let's go ahead and
try to squeeze this game in
so um i don't really have much to tell
about the opening it's just
normal i don't think well since the game
was like
12 years ago opening has updated but
there's nothing wrong with what they are
playing that's a normal
i believe started from grunfeld could
transpose to a lot of other things
but um i think this is just a very
normal opening we shouldn't worry about
it
so in the game uh black made a mistake
and played this
night 8 d7
what do you think is why do you think
this is a bad move
she is he is a very strong grandmaster
and he's
he's such a nice personality too he's
always smiling
well yeah so the best one was knight c6
but in the game chaperone played knight
d7
and um it's my understanding that knight
d7
is not great because of a5 a4 and
actually topolof did this in the game so
not completely
i'm not going to take credit for a4 but
a4 is a great uh move that's just
very easy to do and when you do this a4
you're actually threatening to capture
this
like win this piece so um
all right in the game black had to kind
of play a5
and now what do you think we should do
as white
what would be different if this knight
was on c6
i'm not playing badly for black take it
up with chaperone if he played this game
poor guy is going to receive facebook
messages
yeah that is true knight on b6 might be
trapped and what about this knight but
if this knight was on c6 it would be
attacking d4 which would
not allow us to play a move like e4 so
question can we play e4 now
uh az you're not wrong i would prefer to
get a lesson from magnus ii
if you get that can we share
so yeah i believe e4 is a cool idea so
after e4
jeperinov just went for e5 um what
doesn't
e5 yeah he's got to do this e5 yep so
after e5 i think simply d5
is the way to go because you don't want
to take this you don't want to allow
this knight
to actually get activated to pose some
threats
you want you want to punish opponents
for playing that
knight d7 ergo d5 and in the game white
black went c6
and so what i think we should do as
white
we just saw a very interesting position
including the last game including how
the pawns were just doing awesome
so
what now
yeah i i was quite impressed with how
the grandmasters are
doing this bomb cloud
yeah we need like a just a tournament of
bonk cloud
and as a prize they would get like the
trophy of like a mushroom bong cloud
anyways um
the somewhat is laughing all right um so
yeah i kind of want to do castle i agree
so
in order to do that cast though we got
to get some bishops out
but we don't really know what to do with
this bishop yet and
also we don't really want to allow the
opponent to take
in his terms we want do we want to do
this pawn exchange in our terms
so what do you think about bishop g5
i kind of really like bishop g5 by the
way
yeah bishop g5 now i'm trying to trick
you if you
play f6 that is the funeral for this guy
if he plays bishop f6 which you did in
the game now we can do bishop e3
now there's a nice little hole for us to
try and poke around
possibly
so now
in this position box just played queen
e7 and so my question for you guys
um why to move can we do this d6
whoa no stop coloring just want one
error there we go
can we play this d6
ah thank you anubha
yep i i like d6 well the thing is with
d6 nobody is really attacking you
so um nobody is going to be able to
disturb that d6
and the d6 is kind of like putting all
of the queen side just
in a huge pressure and i really like
that
pressure is my best friend so after
d6 queen e6 what do you think black
wants
true if black makes its end game that
pawn is gonna be very lonely i agree
so if it's black to move um
black could probably want to attack this
right so
something knight c4 so let's stop that
i think d6 is only good if you actually
go ahead with a move like b3
if you don't do better and you're just
sitting there like all right
we're gonna wait for potential uh knight
c4 you can eat my
um pawns i i
yeah i said that uh earlier in here
when i just mentioned that f6 kind of
kills off your bishop
that's why we don't want it i mean we
want it as white black doesn't want it
black shouldn't do it
and now b3 in the game
chaperone i've just played bishop g7
i don't fully understand bishop g7 i
think bishop g7 was to stop something
with bishop h6 but i
it doesn't seem like white had the
intention of bishop h6 immediately
so i think bishop g7 was just played so
maybe black would play like knight f6 i
think that was the only reason
um so after bishop g7
what do you guys think we should do i'll
give you two options
h4 or get your bishop out on castle
exactly if so there's still some
confusions on why
we didn't take on c6 it's my
understanding
that taking on d6 you would give your
opponents
some chances to get uh get out
so just if you took whoa
that's that's a fun take if you took
took then there would be like a bishop
a6
then yes the pawn structure would be a
little messed up but
um there would also the pressure would
be gone
i prefer pressure all right h4
exactly black went to f5 knight g5
queen has to go to f6 i mean could
technically go to e82 but
f6 is the better one so this game is
actually
bro this this move right now is
brilliant
so what do you guys think white should
do
we already can see that we have a clear
advantage
in spatial advantage and basically all
over the board
but is there anything that we can
improve
i am reading the comments from this chat
exactly you got to go after the king
so something like h5 could be
interesting but my problem is if you
play h5
f4 you got to move the bishop you lose
the knight
so we can't really touch this just yet
so we should right now it takes a lot of
understanding
to realize that we should just let the
king's side be
we should just take a break from the
king side then improve the queen side
so how are we going to improve the queen
side bam
b4 if he takes it
check i'm going to pick that up and i'm
attacking your knight
and now black is just paralyzed you
can't touch this knight you can't touch
this knight you can't push
this bishop it's horrible
so in the game japanese didn't take and
he played f4
so after f4
we have two options bring the bishop
back take that knight which one do you
think we should do
keep in mind the spirit of dynamic chess
you shouldn't really give your opponents
chance to have a free
move to do whatever he wants
that being said we gotta take it so a
lot of things are just very fast very
fast very forceful
so take take take now
if you were to take back well that's
that's a lovely blunder i'm going to
come here
give you a hello and eat that guy so you
can't take back
so in the game japanese played knight d7
now here um we could potentially do
something with like my
check and then knight e6 but then we
would
allow rook takes a5 and this trick would
get a little activated
what do you guys think about what do you
guys think is the best move
i see some hellos hi you're getting in a
very interesting position
oh yeah exactly bruce we gotta push it i
don't know if you went this push but
we're gonna go with this push
yeah a6 is the best move
the thing is if you take it well now i'm
gonna have
a lot of um well
activity first of all second of all i
can just do this
now this is what i wanted to do but my
problem was if i did
this in the other position if i did it
too early
you would take on a5 and now black would
have
some counter play some hopes we don't
want black to have any hopes
so that is why we played this a6
and after um
[Music]
after a6 in the game black blacklight
kh8 to avoid
the checks and as white
oh this is such a great move
so what do you guys think we should do
now
this is an amazing move
surprisingly you're not pushing forward
no i said we're not pushing forward
um no 92 just kind of
um blocks it all
what do you guys think about knight b1
weird huh
but the idea is pretty clear i need to
retreat
honestly i would not see this in my game
i would not be playing knight b1
if i do knight b1 i i feel like i need
to get checked
for extra chess in my brain but knight
b1 is just one of those moves it's
great i know i wouldn't see it but
well not to paul off um so
i don't expect you guys to see it but
let's try to understand it
so knight b1 i i think the idea is that
i'm just kind of taking my knight away
so if you take care
i'll take there whoa ah way too many
arrows
whoa whoa all right i have
arrowed this a lot there's a lot of
errors here a lot of green arrows
okay um
maybe yeah maybe knife when i do knight
b1 um
they're gonna do like a honorary gm norm
mail to me yeah um
so knight d1 black went bishop h6 let's
bring the knight back
take take and we finally got the seventh
rank two
and the funny thing is we we also have
like one more pawn we're not even
sacrificing anything
um so after c7 take
voila and in the game chaperone went
with queen f5
to try and pick up another piece well
pick up a piece
pick up the last the sacrificed piece
that he just did and um i
don't think that we should really worry
about it especially because we still
have this guy
and one thing that i would like to
mention is look how we're not even
really using these two so we got to
start using them
but we have to be very careful on
how my understanding is
that we don't really know what to do
with this bishop
and also e4 and queen a5s are coming up
so we got to move this knight so
knight g5
and after knight g5 uh in the game
black chaperone of uh played
bishop g7 so now why to move what do you
think we should do and heads up the game
is going to be over in few moves
that doesn't mean that necessarily you
you're going to have to like sacrifice a
bunch of stuff
but it means that black is really
horrible
i see somehow new hellos
muhammad you might want to stick around
for the end game class
which might happen with a little delay
because
i need to wrap this up
exactly bishop c4 exactly easy peasy
uh bishop c2 now what should we do
in for our queen don't you want to cast
them nope
not necessarily so i think that's also a
very common misconception in chess that
everybody says you have to cast all but
that's not true
you have to keep your king safe and you
have to get your pieces developed you
castle to get your king safe and to get
your work out
so if you have if you can achieve that
without castling
and we did one um we did one uh
other lesson on chess and psychology
thank you for um
should we castle and yeah i think those
were some great games
all right so queen d5 exactly we want to
do queen g8
uh maybe not right now maybe if he makes
a mistake then we do that
but i don't think he would be making a
mistake
soon anyways queen d5 great
uh black point is h6 and
now rf7 if you take it
i'll take back and now this is winning
right
this is just also this guy's just
waiting to be eaten
so in the game chaperone i played queen
seed i can't even imagine
having this position well it's just for
the fun of it let's take a look
this is horrible okay
let's get back to white all right that's
much better
um and so in this position can somebody
tell me
one move and then white is just super
winning
actually what is super winning right now
so somebody asked where's the psychology
in
this game especially in this game
with dynamic chess you have to have a
very strong psychological understanding
of chess to do
all these pressures and if if the
if the dynamic attack is happening to
you you have to have a very strong
mentality
strong psychology understanding to be
able to hold your
hold your game there were a few
instances that black could have done
better so exactly rook takes g7 is the
best one
and here i believe separative resigned
because if take
just check queen e7 and bye bye rook
and then d7 is also coming up it's
horrible it's
just mating two or three of them anyways
amazing two
right two not even three yeah so this
this
is it and um this was a very awesome
power play
so topalov did like all of these
psychological dynamics
preparation he did all of it and
that's kind of why i wanted to show you
these games that
show you that when i say psychology and
chess i don't necessarily mean that you
have to
always sit there plan little stuff plan
like maneuvers from night from a1
to like h8 you shouldn't do stuff like
that you should be
using these psychological
understandings of like putting pressure
making your opponents feel quite
miserable
and just all these things that we've
been talking about
and use your skills to win the game
using psychology not just relying on it
alright so i am gonna uh start the end
game
class pretty soon feel free to join us
over there
and yeah see you soon
you